disease-causing microbes continue to
evolve evading host defenses defeating
drugs and spreading antibiotic
resistance recently emerged fretts such
as Zika and Ebola are certain to evolve
in ways that can be hard to predict
scientists must work with dangerous
strains sometimes even engineering new
ones understand these bugs the next
president will need to make sure these
labs are secure and get the country
prepared for a pandemic while figuring
out how to encourage the development of
new antibiotics the advent of CRISPR
allows unprecedented precision editing
of genomes this could lead to cures for
disease and better pest control but also
ethical and regulatory challenges the
next president will likely have to
contend with the techniques potential to
edit human embryos and how this approach
is regulated in plants and animals
around the world sea levels are rising a
few millimeters a year on average but
all sea level rise is local u.s. East
Coast sea levels are rising at double
the global rate and at triple the
average in Virginia the next president
will have to wrestle with protecting
billions of dollars of infrastructure
and helping seaside communities prepare
and adapt to rising waters brain health
touches us from cradle to grave
and when brain disease strikes the costs
personal and budgetary are staggering as
the US population ages Alzheimer's and
dementia are on the rise at the other
end of life the prevalence of autism and
learning disabilities has jumped the new
president will have to plan for a ramp
up in spending on brain disease that
will put a squeeze on federal healthcare
budgets and decide how high a priority
to place on spending for basic brain
research ai is already having an impact
on society products and services from
self-driving cars to systems that guide
medical care and treatment could bring
major benefits including increased
productivity and fewer deaths from
traffic accidents but letting machines
make their own decisions also raises
profound ethical legal and regulatory
questions
the administration will need to keep a
close eye on a eyes impact on the
economy workforce and national security
when experts calculate risk they rely on
statistics but ordinary people tend to
rely on their guts both approaches have
their pitfalls misperception of risk can
push a president to overreact to lesser
threats and under react to greater
problems and how a president
communicates with the public about risk
can mean the difference between sowing
panic and maintaining calm the next
president will face a long list of
policy decisions surrounding known risks
including terrorists attacks foreign
conflicts domestic crime and violence
flu pandemics and natural disasters